[Musique]
il a été journaliste et notamment
journaliste sportif il est aussi poète
il est organisateur de salon dans le
salon du livre des ncours c'est Bernard
de lâre bonjour merci Patrice de de
m'accueillir vous allez bien ça va ça va
ça va ou ça va bien alors euh on va
parler évidemment vous avez une
actualité un peu chargé parce que il va
y avoir le le Salon du livre de lcour
don vous vous occupez depuis quelques
années qui aura lieu le 10 décembre
prochain on va en parler dans dans
quelques instants mais euh c'est vrai
que vous avez fait disait beaucoup de
choses avez été journaliste sportif on
parlera de sport tout à l'heure puisque
c'est un c'est un élément important puis
comme il va y avoir aussi les Jeux
Olympiques sur ce sur ce territoire donc
c'est important mais vous vous êtes
aussi poète et vous publiez un un
nouveau recueil de poème c'est pas le
premier hein c'est le
3èè euh alors quand le petit enfant
paraît hein alors il il y avait une
pièce qui s'appelait lorsque l'enfant
paraî qui racontait un peu les les les
déboirs à l'époque des ce qu'on appelait
les filles mères hein une PCE d'André
Roussin et puis il y a il y a surtout
mais il y a surtout et ça se
rapprocherait plus de
ça le le fameux opus de de Victor Hugo
l'art d'être grand-père ouais c'est ça
qui m'a inspiré en fait j'adore Victor
Hugo et là je suis arrivé grand-père sur
le tard pour des raisons que voilà
mais bien sûr de ma fille surtout c'est
un c'est vraiment j'ai relu Victor Hugo
c'est formable ouais alors il y a des
anecdotes dingues parce que et puis
c'est vrai il y a quelque chose de vrai
c'est que bah les parents ont une
responsabilité forte vis-à-vis de
l'éducation des enfants Les
grands-parents c'est différ Diffon pas
la M responsabilité puis quand on se
rapproche vraiment enfin nous on a fait
le mais on voit cette vie cette force de
vie d'un petit enfant c'est énorme quoi
c'est on reconnaît le miracle de la vie
ce mystère aussi qu'est-ce qui va
devenir ce bébé c'est tous les c'est
tellement d'espérance c'est vraiment du
du bonheur quoi et on redécouvre tout
avec lui c'est vraiment vous êtes un
Grand- père heureux ouais ben tout à
fait ou tout à fait et là vous allez je
sais pas quel âge quel âge il a là 2 ans
2 ans il a fêé ses 2 ans d'accord donc
dans dans quelques temps vous allez
pouvoir lui montrer des des des poèmes
que vous avez écrit pour lui au fond B
bien sûr ouais c'était le but un peu
j'essaie de lui donner des piste un peu
d'expérience j'espère qu'il les lira
quand il aura 20 ans 15 16 ans tout ça
peut-être avant même avant 20 ans quand
même avant ouais c'est pas B écoutez
c'est pas tous les jours qu'un enfant
quand il Naé quelqu'un lui quelqu'un lui
dédie un recueil de de poème alors il
est dédié il est dédié plutôt à votre
mère d'ailleurs he je cro mère de H
enfants h enfants ah bon h enfants vous
éties h en ça je suis habitué moi
j'étais le deuxè donc j'ai un frère dont
je suis le le Parin qui a 10 ans de
moins que moi quoi je suis habitué à
m'occuper vous êtes habitué au grande
famille ouis et dans les grandes
familles dans les familles de huit
enfants c'est les enfants qui s'occupent
des autres enfants plus plus que les
plus que quand il y a 12 12 ans d'écart
c'est évident tout ça et ça ça allège
les tâes de la maman quoi du papa alors
le le recueil est il y a plusé en
plusieurs parties ça commence bah avant
avant la naissance le moment où on
attend la grossesse comment ça va se
passer
tout ça voilà on achète plein de choses
le gamin arrive il a déjà plein de oui
c'est ça il la chambre est pleine déjà
quand quand il arrive euh il y a il y a
l'accouchement l'accouchement ouis qui
est toujours un cap difficile pour une
femme c'est du sport ENF maintenant avec
la périurale voilà il y a heureusement
la péridurale mais il y a beaucoup
d'inquiétude quand même c'est c'est on
porte pas un gamin comme ça c'est c'est
est-ce que est-ce que vous croyez pas
d'ailleurs qu'on est plus inquiet
peut-être aujourd'hui que les femmes ne
l'étent B je sais pas quand vot mère eu
h enfants euh ah ben ouais à la fin ça
passe comm à la poste
qu'on dit je suis pas sûr que ça soit
vrai c'est ce que disent les mecs hein
non non mais c'est vrai que c'est quand
on est plus rodé puis l'âge aussi de la
maman qui joue quoi un accouchement
après 40 ans c'est plus dur que quand on
a 20 ans c'est ça aussi physiquement
c'est ça aussioui c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui on a aussi ENF les femmes
comme les hommes d'ailleurs ont des
enfants un petit peu plus tard hein
parce que on se consacre d'abord à son
souvent à son boulot à son sa vie
professionnelle est Victor Hugo mais
disait les les femmes sont des temples
ell portent la vie sont des temples
devant lequel il faut s'agenouiller
absolument oua c'est non mais c'est vrai
il faut les femmes c'est quand même des
porteuses de la vie quoi c'est vraiment
énorme quoi il ont et pour l'instant oui
on n pas
trouvé manière encore que encore que le
problème de la naissance est en train de
d'évoluer euh qui qui sont vos euh maîre
à penser en matière de poésie
de Victor Hugo et j'aime bien aussi les
les poètes Blais sandrard et Guillaume
apoliner les les poètes on dit toujours
les poètes les les voyageurs alors ouais
puis des gens engagés dit les poètes
c'est des gens dou des rêveurs mais
aussi bien Guillaume Apolinaire que GL
Sandra engagé volontaire en 1418 et tous
deux étaient étrangers Guillaume
polinaire était polonais c'est pas son
vrai nom et pareil bless Sandra son vrai
nom c'est Frédéric Sauser nationalité
suisse ils étaient pas obligés d'aller
en 1418 et ben ils y sont allés par
amour de la France et de ce que
représentait on voit ce qu'à l'époque
représentait la France cétait vraiment
le symbole du pays de la liberté et les
gens étaient prêts à mettre leur leur
leur vie dans la balance pour défendre
ses valeurs de liberté ça a changé
malheureus et puis c'est des c'est des
poètes qui ont changer quand
même à la face de la Poie à la fin tu es
là de ce monde ancien c'est c'est un
polinaire et le transibérien de ah ou
c'est magn il a bougé les lignes
deécriture boug il av fait P y oui pas
York oui quand je disais que cétait un
voyageur un peu plutôt bless s tout
jeune il avait il est allé en en Russie
douj avec un vendeur de bijou en fait
une histoire oui aprè une vie de de
roman enfin puis il a décrit la la
guerre de 1418 quoi de façon phénoménale
il raconte dans les tranché alors par la
main coupée il dit le gars voilà il fait
ben c'est un italien il est puis après
ça se termine une page et demi après on
a vu la moitié du corps emporté par un
but quoi tout que ça puis lui-même a
perdu le bras droit à l'attaque d'un for
et ce qui est ce qui est fort aussi
c'est qu'il avait fait quelques années
avant un poème où il disait qu'il rêvait
que ses mains s'envolaient et ça
arrivait dans la la réalitéé c'est
énorme souvent les les poètes voit les
choses avant qu'ellearrive je pense ils
ont des connexions Victor Hugo éta un
visionnaire il avait prédu le tunnel
sous la Manche il avait prévu les
guerres franco-allemandes bah il a il a
défendu l'Europe aussi 180 il avit dit
faut faire les États-Unis d'Europe les
Américains qu'ils ont fait c top il faut
que l'Europe fasse ça et si on l'avait
écouté on en serait peut-être pas où on
en est non c'est vrai que c'était et en
plus il a une vie politique c'est Boué
il a commencé à droite il a fini à
gauche son enterrement c'est quand même
quelque chose de fabuleux avec les les
prostitué qui ah ou ou il paraî qu'il y
avait plus de monde que pour Johnny quoi
ah oui oui il y avait plus de monde et
puis les prostitués faisaient des prix
ouais c'est ça parce que il défendait le
peuple il il a créé des des beau
personnages de prostitué
misérable quand quand il était guerneset
exilé 17 ans quand même il paraî que les
les les les marins enfin les les gens du
peuple les Bretons les Normands ils se
baladaent avec les les poèmes de Victor
Hugo et ils vendaient les livres s le
mteau par sils étaient pris par cha
c'était une époque où la poésie était
très populaire est-ce qu'elle l'
aujourd'hui un peu moins elle elle est
moins ben parce qu'à l'époque il y avait
pas la télé il y avait pas la radio donc
les les auteurs les journaux se
vendaient beaucoup en 14 il y avait 100
quotidiens à Paris 100
quotidienouit communiquit comme ça mais
est-ce que la chanson parfois on dit la
chanson a pris la place de la poésie je
pense oui je pense vous prenez Renault
Renault ça dépend des chanteurs aussi ça
dépend ouais mais becoup brassin c'est
un poète c'est évident brassin brê ferra
c'est des PO et vous prenez Renaud
Renault actuel enfin il il a un autre
âge Renaud et Renaud il écrit en
alexandrain vous prenez le mistral
gagnant c'est des alexandrain des ver de
12 pieds
à compliqué à mettre en musique les vers
de 12 pieds ouais non c'est pas parce
que beaucoup de la musique est fait à 4
temps et 3 x 4 12 ça le fait il y a les
vers octosyllabiques sur 8 pieds ça
marche bien avec la musique aussi mais
il y a des enfin enfin on peut bousculer
tout ça maintenant on fait des veres à 9
pieds 6 pieds mais beaucoup on a fait
des veres à 12 pieds à 8 pieds en accord
avec la musique c'est assez facile assez
pratique quoi alors je je vais juste
deux verr d' d'un des poèmes mais parce
qu'il est ce serait presque d'actualité
après la la la la la marche contre
l'antisémitisme et voilà et alors ça
commence comme ça Macron le pain de
Mélenchon tout ça tu t'en
fous tu préfères bien sûr jouer avec ton
doudou
ouais c'est pas mal
ça c'est vrai que c'est vrai que
l'actualité passe au-delà de la tête des
des enfants et mais en même temps il
faut leur apprendre il faut oui
mais je pense la poésie peut la poésie
lutte contre la guerre puisqu'elle est
pour l'amour la vie beaucoup de poètes
c'est l'amour qui chante vous prenez
baudler c'est de l'amour euh euh rimbau
pareil c'est des poèmes d'amour hein
absolument et puis ENF cette phrase
propos des enfants vous riez comme le
printemps et vous pleurez comme l'aurore
ah ça c'est Victor Hugo ça c'est c'est
oui mais c'est vrai hein ouais c'est
vrai ça et donc alors ça s'appelle quand
le petit enfant paraît c'est édition
glyff qui est votre éditeur eu depuis un
moment traditionnel he oua ouais je peux
dire euh un un mot alors euh c'est vrai
que vous j'ai dit vous avez été
journaliste sportif il ce livre chez
l'armatan qui s'appelle Sportissimo
ouais euh courir marcher naviguer c'est
vivre plus fort alors c'est c'est quoi
ce livre Ahou j'étais journaliste
sportif j'ai débuté comme si j'ai fait
ça enfin j'ai jamais lâché le sport
pendant 40 et c'est un peu un essai quoi
de démontrer que la pratique sportive a
évoluer un exemple parmi d'autres moi
quand j'ai débuté il y a 40 ans il y
avait des courses de vélo dans tous les
villages il y avait un club de vélo à
coignère à MPa à Rambouillet à
saint-arnou il y avait des des des
courses cyclistes tous les dimanches cé
un boulot dingue je voudrais rendre
dommage au travail des journalistes
sportifs qui travaillent comme des
dingues tous les weekends une course de
vélo ça commence à 9h ça finit à midi
puis après il y a les résultats plein
non plus une belle vie quand même dans
l'ensemble mais alors j'ai eu la chance
voir les coupe du monde etouis j'ai j'ai
rencontré Thierry péponet parce que vous
savoir que la ville nouvelle a a un
passé olympique hein à un moment elle
avait un bateau en 470 avec péponet
qu'elle sponsorisait qui faisait le tour
de France à la Voise et Thierry
pppponet a été champion de France
olympique en à sou en 88 et j'avais
suivi péponet j'avais sympathisé et
grâce à lui j'ai j'ai passé les permis
de de voile permis au Turier à l'étend
avec le club de W de l'étente 51 j'ai
appris à naviger avec passer le le
permis là-bas allez il faut savoir qu'on
peut faire des croisières d'été avec le
club de Wall de l'étend Saint-Quentin
donc j'ai fait le tour de Corse grâce au
club de Wall de l'étente Saint-Quentin
peu de gens le savent mais c'est un club
qui a plein et donc j'avais suivi
l'entraînement de l'équipe de football
en 84 qui était championne olympique
elle s'entraînait à à GIB surrivette à
l'époque parce qu'il y avait pas le le
Clairefontaine n'existait pas encore
donc plein de choses comme ça on avait
suivi aussi les les tournois des des C
nations à l'époque il s'entraîaient
aussi à CLIRE fontaine au chateau Ricard
donc j'avais suivi plein de trucs comme
ça pas Mar aussi non c'était avant
marcousi c'était aussi au Château Ricard
d'accord et enfin il y a plein
d'anecdotes là-dessus quoi c'était une
chance c'est une belle vie la vie de de
sportif quand même surtout pour un pour
moi un petit gars de soneloir qui vient
de gunon un blé de paumé de 2000
habitants pour moi c'est du rêve quoi
j'en reviens à moimême pas même pas quoi
c'est des trucs que j'imagina même pas
quoi alors et on va parler assez vite
parce qu'il reste plus beaucoup de temps
du Salon des lancour AL le salon du L
qui qui est fait qui existe depuis 6 ans
au départ il a été lancé par les Amis du
passé des lancour qui font aussi les
vignes tous les depuis 30 ans on fait de
la de la vigne ouais on fait du vin du
mous il est bon il est bon mais il est
il est bio à fond aucun produit ch alors
le Parin c'est c'est mon copain Nelson
Monfort ouais un type formidable qui
gagne être connu il faut savoir qu'il
fait du théâtre avec sa oui oui il fait
du théâtre il chante et il a fait un
livre sur jean-f il a fait des oui il
adore la chanson voilà il a vu des ovnis
aussi plein JeanClaude bouré
aussi euh et pu il va venir ici tiens
ben on et pour la première fois le son
du livre aura au prisme aura lieu au
prisme c'est un nveau lieu grand merci
au prisme à la maie des lanc on fera
peut-être une émission avec lui pour
pour annoncer le le voilà le salon euh
et puis il y a un illustrateur Philippe
Laurin
voilà qui a fait des des livres bien il
travaille beaucoup à Pierre Lagrue qui
est plus littéraire et il a fait des
livres sur les cyclistes de légende sur
les les footballeurs de légende les
Olympiques de légende et il fait il a
fait aussi un livre sur les rugbyman de
légende et à cette occasion il fera une
exposition au prisme 10 jours avant le
salon à partir de fin novembre et ça
restera durant tout le temps du salon
tout le salon qu'est-ce qu'il y a
d'autre comme comme auteur et ben on a
aussi beaucoup de journalistes sportifs
on a étié une bon ami qui travaille à
l'équipe qui a fait un livre sur le Tour
de France de 1941 d'acc le thème ça sera
le sport ah oui le sport enfin ouais le
thèm sport et la littérature et ben il y
aura d'autres thèmes aussi il y aura du
polar de la poésie bien sûr mais la
moitié des auteurs sont sur le sport
d'accord bah ce qu' ce que je propose
c'est qu' on a le temps d'en reparler
d'ici le 10 décembre donc hein on
reviendra viendrez peut-être avec avec
Nelson ou pour l'annoncer merci beaucoup
Bernard je rappelle quand le petit
enfant paraît c'est aux éditions glyf
voilà alors si vous êtes si vous êtes
parents si vous êtes grands-pents les
grands parents V se reconnaî si vous
voulez offrir un beau cadeau de Noël à
votre à votre petit enfant par exemple
voilà précipitez-vous sur ce recqu de PO
de Bernard de lre merci beaucoup merci
[Musique]
Patrice